and tonight it's brady singer facing the
pirates for the first time
really you would expect a lot out of
brady after his last outing
but this young man here he has the three
pitches that can get it done
and now i tom fastball
so tom does not advance the runner and
that's out number one
blue casey pitch tracks oh we love him
look at that
show you the nice run on that two seamer
there it is watch it take off
that's right he did the job there just
got on him too quickly couldn't get the
barrel on it and
left his runner there at second base
nice job singer
here's brian reynolds and that's well
hit to left field
ben attendee is at the track and he's
got it
what a great read hud and good instincts
he ran
to the spot where he thought the ball
was going to be absolutely and
we can tell by the sound of the bat that
that ball was hit hard we can tell
always if it's hit hard
so can he the outfielders can as well
the last minute adjustment he made you
see
look down there look at this adjustment
right here staying with it the ball had
backspin on it
that's a fine play for brady singer what
i mean by that is
he had to take his eye off the ball
twice and just in his mind calculating
where he thought it was going to land
sight unseen see will crow's number
brought to you by the pennsylvania
lottery
hopefully uh he'll do good work with
that fastball but mirrorfield with
50 hits two balls one strike
yeah deep short jump throw
by newman is not in time and what's on
to begin the bottom of the first
nah ball wasn't hit hard enough newman's
showing his skills and he's got plenty
of them
and whit he's going to beat out for
seamer
up in the zone whit wanted to stay on
top of it and hit it just slow enough
that we could beat that out
again tonight both teams get their lead
off man aboard
in the first inning so hit number 51 for
mayor field
talk about ben and tendy down in the
condo in two
and benintendi hits it into right center
field on an 02 pitch
and now he's digging for second he look
at that slide they're going to call him
out
but ben intended he thinks he's out he
gives the royals a one-nothing lead
that's all right i was just getting
ready to say
even with two strikes on him owen two uh
you got confidence in this guy now let's
watch the slide here
watch him he is he stops it he knows
that he's gonna get tagged out
but did he put the nah he got it joe was
right
good try though you know that's that is
a very difficult play for an infielder
to try to put the tag on a guy like that
that's why you just got to go right into
them sometimes you throw your whole body
on them
the bases are full of bucks for reynolds
nobody out boy this is a great
opportunity
the 1-1 base hit right field in comes
one they're gonna hold
tom and that's gonna be an rbi single
for brian reynolds
and the pirates have tied it at one just
kind of moved the conga line up a little
bit now
yeah maybe it'll be a big party this
inning that was a change up right there
circle change it gives up a run on a
pitch he very seldom throws which will
also make him mad
yeah reynolds with his 24th run batted
in gregory polanco with the bases loaded
still
nobody out and that's roped out to
center deep enough
to get frazier home also tom will tag
and head to third
it's a sac fly for polanco and the
pirates have their first lead of the
night
i'll take that but i'm still waiting for
that big hit to cash in this situation
and a slider that kind of down and away
so tom good score on another one of
those ben gamil struck out last hitting
that one hit out to deep center field
that should get tom holm
that will be number three and a good job
for
gamel as well another sac fly pirates
lead three to one in the third
lead off batter kevin newman and newman
with the base hit to right to start the
pirates fourth inning
and for the second straight inning
pittsburgh has their lead off man
on three of the four times they've had
that lead dog on now michael perez
left-handed batter the 1-0 is swung on
and belted in the gap
and newman already around second he's
almost a third by the time that ball's
picked up in the outfield he'll score on
perez's double the pirates leading
4-1 another slide there's been a
bunch of those sliders barreled up
tonight
you see how long both outfielders have
to run just to get there that will bring
salvador perez to the plate
this game needs a shot of energy oh
there's the shot we're looking for and
that ball
is out of here home run salvador perez
and the royals have closed the
pittsburgh lead to four to three
you just had the feeling that salvi was
due the way he's been swinging the bat
the way
pittsburgh has been pitching and salvi
got one in his wheelhouse
and ripped a screaming line drive that
just
cleared the fence and went into the
pittsburgh bullpen it only went 375 feet
because of that
laser line drive but it was hit at 113
miles an hour
so taylor triples lopez walks and there
are two on for whit
and there's a line drive base hit into
left field whit
ties the game with his second hit and
the royals still have
two on with nobody out yeah there it is
again i'll tell you that
those breaking balls they he's gonna
make some adjustments on those and he
probably won't be able to make those
until he does his next bullpen session
because the royals are all over them and
they're not missing him that's the thing
you can get hanging sliders and hanging
curves
and you know you pop them up or or you
ground them out
but the royals are putting them in play
for hits so lopez
is at third he walked merrifield's at
second he's driven in the run santana
has walked
and here's ben attendee who drove in a
run in the first inning
an attendee cranks it to right
that's way back and that's gone a grand
slam
for andrew benintendi and the royals
take an
eight to four lead andrew benintenti
wasn't waiting around
he jumped on the first pitch and hit it
into the royals bullpen
and a lot of high fives and smiles in
that royals dugout
the most difficult man to face in the
lineup is up and adam frazier
frazier pops it up left side going out
his gutierrez tough play
and did he make the catch he did not and
a run will score
to make it eight to five that was a
difficult play for gutierrez the ball
directly over his head
he sprinted out towards that left field
line
and the ball just did glance off of his
glove
as he reached for it and just could not
make the play
that is a base hit it's a two-two count
got reynolds right now and polanco
waiting his turn on deck
how about that was that a swing play at
the plate
he's out gonna say that reynolds got in
salvador perez way
not allowing salvi to make a play at the
plate that's the call
now he tagged him but that looks like an
out
i don't know if he said swing it looked
like he was pointing to
reynolds being in the area there was no
immediate call
on the swing by dan bolino there was no
appeal
to the first base umpire edwin moscoso
the pirates get one
and el salvador perez coming up there's
the pitch salvador perez
it's been high in the air deep to left
that's a way back
and salvi's done it again a two-home run
night for salvador perez the royals lead
it
nine to five that's two souvenirs the
guys have tonight
and salvi now with 12 home runs
now taylor had the other triple
taylor skies one out into medium depth
right center
runner tags throw home is cut off the
royals have run number 10.
so taylor picks up run battered in
number 19.
the royals make the most of gutierrez
three base hit
ben gamel with two down one and two
on the ground to whit and that is a
two-game sweep
final score 10-5